mientras el mundo observa el caos y el
terror en el aeropuerto de kabul miles
de civiles afganos buscan una huida
terrestre a través de la montañosa
frontera con el vecino pakistán donde
también se están viviendo escenas de
tensión entre los militares paquistaníes
y los migrantes creíamos que íbamos a
cruzar esta frontera fácilmente pero la
situación aquí también es mala este
viernes acnur pidió a los países vecinos
de afganistán mantener sus fronteras
abiertas pakistán comparte una zona
limítrofe de 2 mil 670 km pronosticando
una crisis sin precedentes
hinson en cuanto a números nos estamos
preparando para unos 500.000 nuevos
refugiados en la región
eso en el peor de los casos escenario no
es la primera vez que pakistán recibe la
llegada masiva de refugiados afganos el
éxodo inició hace cuatro décadas durante
la invasión soviética a finales de 1980
había más de 4 millones de afganos en
pakistán según una amnistía
internacional y las cifras aumentaron
con la llegada del grupo talibán y la
posterior invasión estadounidense en la
actualidad se estima que hay más de 15
millones de refugiados afganos
registrados en el país vecino y cerca de
otro millón de refugiados y regular me
llamo hat pedimos de kandahar allí hubo
combates mucho tiempo y libros llegaron
los talibanes y no hubo trabajo para
nosotros ni siquiera podemos ganar
dinero para alimentar a nuestros hijos
por eso hemos venido pakistán cuando
vuelva la paz a afganistán y se acabe el
conflicto volveremos a nuestro país
siempre están ha dicho que no aceptará
más refugiados el cruce fronterizo de
spin boldak chamán continúa abierto con
un flujo diario de unas 20.000 personas
en las últimas horas la unión europea
comenzó a dialogar con las autoridades
de pakistán y otras naciones de la
región para brindar ayuda humanitaria y
evitar así que estos refugiados lleven a
europa